[Música]
aqui é meu pai meus irmãos eu sou essa
garotinha no cantinho com frio encolhida
é era domingo verão de janeiro
nós passamos o dia no clube ao retornar
do clube
ele deixa a gente em casa e falou para
minha mãe vai dando banho nas crianças
que eu vou até a padaria comprar um
lanche e eu trago lanche pra gente
jantar
ele foi até a padaria quando estava
voltando da padaria ele sofreu um ataque
do coração perdeu a direção do carro e
veio a falecer depois que ele faleceu
minha mãe viúva com 28 anos cinco
crianças para criar é preciso sair para
trabalhar pediu ajuda da minha avó a mãe
dela dona ieda uma mulher forte e
determinada
ao invés de 6 no peito ela tinha uma
cicatriz ela tinha câncer e eu nunca via
da vítima dessa doença é nunca vi ela
estava sempre maquiada bem arrumada de
salto tava sempre muito atarefada com a
nossa educação com a costura uma
excelente costureira e ela falava pra
mim eu vou te ensinar ser uma mulher
ideal que era uma mulher ideal para
doneda ela teria que saber lavar passar
e cultura' e eu e keninha eu não queria
fazer isso e ela falava 'não eu não
tenho tempo preciso te ensinar isso
muito rápido
agora você não entende agora você quer
brincar lá na frente um dia você vai
entender
e você vai até me agradecer obrigada
planeta
[Música]
o daniel me criou até os 11 anos ensinou
a lavar passar cuspir a costurar
cozinhar e aos 11 anos ela quando estava
com 11 anos ela faleceu e foi uma época
muito complicado tive que assumir então
a posição de mulher da casa enquanto
minha mãe trabalhava e cuidar de três
irmãos menores
eu costumo brincar que esses meus três
irmãos foram os meus três primeiros
clientes que se ele fizesse uma
reclamação para o sac nevinha o podia
perder um dos meus clientes não imagina
foi uma época bem difícil a única ajuda
que a gente tinha era da igreja batista
ele trazia uma cesta básica no final do
mês já não tinha muita coisa dentro do
armário dessa cesta básica e eu aprendi
com a minha avó fazer um pãozinho
só que como não tinha todos os
ingredientes dessa cesta básica me virar
vale com que tinha de fazer o pão com um
pouco de farinha óleo que tinha sobrado
e falava pra eles comem enquanto está
quente porque depois que aquele esfriava
virava uma pedra para bebê tinha um
terreno em frente em casa tinha muita
folha de capim santo ea folha de capim
santo e lhe dá um chá delicioso foram os
melhores cafés da tarde que eu tive na
minha vida
claro primeiro ele alimentava matava a
minha fome dos meus irmãos e era uma
brincadeira só porque o pãozinho depois
ficava duro e aí virava brincadeira mas
daí eu tirei uma lição que eu vi usar
mais uma lição que eu vi usar nos dias
de hoje né pra gente fazer tudo o que a
gente pode com o mínimo de recursos que
a gente tem é que comecei a trabalhar
com 13 anos
aos 16 eu já era vendedora de loja
trabalhei por muitos anos como vendedora
de loja me casei tive meu primeiro filho
e em 2004 me separei
foi uma passagem da minha vida pessoal
muito
aplicada também essa separação eu me
senti um lixo como mulher eu me sentir
um lixo como profissional porque onde eu
estava não havia perspectiva mais de
crescimento já tinha alcançado o último
posto que era ser a gerente da loja mas
eu sentia que naquele emprego meu
talento ali estava sendo desperdiçado
nessa situação e me vi eu queria estava
muito triste eu queria mudar eu só não
sabia como né e nem por onde começar
então comecei casando de novo com um
moreno alto charmosão em 2006 eu fui
convidada para uma festa e precisei usar
um vestido bacana e pedir emprestado
porque eu não tinha esse vestido bacana
bonito minha colega tim presta pra mim
ele me emprestou vestido quando foi
devolver esse vestido eu queria devolver
lhe lavado passado apesar de saber fazer
isso muito bem
modéstia à parte eu queria fazer isso
por uma lavanderia profissional
sou moradora da periferia de são paulo
município de carapicuíba e fazendo umas
buscas ali na região da morávia
descobrir que não tinha lavanderia que
para usar uma lavanderia precisaria
atravessar para o lado rico da cidade ou
ir para o centro da cidade e eu fiquei
com aquilo na cabeça como que as
mulheres como que as pessoas que moram
aqui na região fazem para cuidar do
enxoval das suas casas elas têm uma
roupa bacana que elas querem ter um
cuidado melhor eu fiquei com aquilo na
cabeça e decidir
taí uma boa idéia de demissão antes de
pedir demissão como sou boba foi até o
banco e pedir um empréstimo pessoal
junto e dez mil reais e abrir a primeira
lavanderia sem ter uma única máquina de
lavar
eu fui até essas lavanderias do centro e
do bairro rico e falei olha eu tenho uma
lavanderia é eu tenho uma demanda muito
grande de roupa e eu queria eu não tô
dando conta de fazer esse serviço eu
queria ver se vocês conseguem lavar
essas peças pra mim por um preço menor
que não valerá tanto
lá na frente o meu cliente algumas
toparam e abrir a lavanderia trabalhei
muito
foi um ano de trabalho sozinha é a única
ajuda que eu tinha é dessas outras
lavanderias nessa região eu percebi
também que o que ele fez crescer era que
as mulheres a maioria trabalha fora o
problema não era lavar roupa o problema
da mulherada era passar roupa eu comecei
oferecendo um pacote de passadoria do
que a mesa o ferro tinha trazido de casa
e isso foi é um bom humor foi falando
pra outra foi falando para o período da
noite a mulher não tem tempo de fazer
realmente não gosta né demanda muito
tempo é muito cansativo ea mulher de
hoje em dia trabalhando filho caso
estudo não tem muito tempo pra isso
o negócio foi crescendo é hoje
isso foi em 2007 né hoje há a lavanderia
tem uma rede já com quatro lojas um
galpão onde a gente centraliza todos
serviço a maior parte do serviço
centralizado nesse galpão
todas elas me geram lucro e o que eu vim
aqui na verdade dizer que às vezes você
pra realizar um sonho pra você achar que
você quer entender se você tem uma idéia
que você precisa ter muito dinheiro o
que você só pode vender um serviço ou
vender um produto é se fosse um
determinado padrão de público que vá ter
dinheiro para poder pagar por esse
serviço segundo a onu 30% da população
urbana vive na periferia tem muita gente
lá que tem sim dinheiro pra gastar vai
poder pagar pelo serviço e precisa de
muita coisa e não é atendida não tem
então se você tem um sonho né você sonha
grande começa pequeno e aí tentar
realizar ele aos pouquinhos
então assim não precisa começar grande
é só ter o sonho grande obrigada
[Aplausos]